now after a year where many of us were
social distancing
larger in-person holiday gatherings are
back a recent poll found two-thirds of
american adults are planning to gather
with friends or family outside their
households this thanksgiving but for
many people the return of family get
togethers can bring anxiety and tension
psychologists and cbs news contributor
lisa demour joins us right now so let's
talk about this because hanging out with
a family during the holidays can be very
complicated what is your advice so my
advice is probably out of the gate if
you know it's going to be complicated go
ahead and lower your expectations i
think people sometimes think it's the
holidays it should be fun it should be
wonderful but if the people who are with
you are not your first choice it's
probably better to separate the idea of
the holidays from the idea of having a
good time and to think thanksgiving
we'll get through it
when everybody leaves then we'll turn to
really enjoying ourselves
no we just have vastly different
approaches here you know nate says he if
it gets a little complicated and he
walks away
i'll just disappear right duck off into
a room where nobody's at and i'll find
myself um with peace and quiet and i
kind of stir the pot a little bit you
know i'm like trying to charge it up
because i i love engagement as you do
here by the way
so what's the right approach well it
depends on who you are right so if you
can stir the pod in a way that is
respectful and kind and engaging and
have a good rich conversation
more power to you if you know that the
best strategy for you is to politely
excuse yourself or to nod and then
change the subject that's also a good
strategy i think one of the things we
want to remember on the holidays is that
just because somebody throws something
doesn't mean you have to catch it
i like that so you can just politely
move on to a new topic this does not
mean you are letting people walk all
over you it means you are being tactical
it means you're being strategic it means
you're basically saying thanksgiving my
goal is not to get into a fight it's to
get through it in a nice way and then
move on
if you're the host where all these
family members are gathering you have a
choice you can plan nothing because then
there's no conflict you may think or
plan an activity what do you prefer of
the options i would do the third option
which is have something you can bring
out if you need it
so if it's not going well if it's tense
and people aren't getting along then
it's probably a good idea to say there's
a hike that i have planned there's
something
that you're all gonna love or there's a
service activity we can go do
having some structure can break up the
tension i like how it sounds almost like
a threat like if you don't get along
you're gonna go on this type
all right so um another hot topic of
conversation will be vaccination status
and how do you handle that when it comes
to friends and family that are coming
over uh because it might be a difficult
conversation before people step into
your house to say wait a minute where's
your card what's your status before you
walk into my home
this is tough because people are all
over the map on this and they're also
all over the map with their risk
tolerance
but the rapid tests have made this a lot
easier right because whatever people's
vaccination status is we can actually
confirm safety on the spot so if it
feels like it's going to be weird maybe
make it kind of fun say we're going to
start with hors d'oeuvres in the garage
you know we'll have drinks we'll do our
rapid test and then come on in right you
can
make it playful make it fun and then be
able to enjoy the holiday because you're
not worried about safety
all right yeah what about stamina
[Laughter]
it's long it's a four day weekend uh
should you suggest people get on the
road on friday
you know this is hard i mean we're out
of practice we're out of practice with
being together we're out of the practice
with being with lots of people
i think we can be gentle with ourselves
and just acknowledge that this is
different this is new
i also think i think nate's strategy of
quietly excusing oneself when you need
to take a break um there's a lot of jobs
at thanksgiving so it's easy to excuse
oneself it's easy to say i'm gonna go
start some dishes i'm gonna go work on
getting the pie that's really good so
take advantage of the labor-intensive
quality of thanksgiving to get yourself
out of the room back to the activity
though i want to know is there a tried
or true
fun-loving like
game or or thing you would not do to to
get us through
there are fights around monopoly i'm
serious but i also mini golf maybe maybe
or a certain activity i think if you
really want to get through the holidays
great ones
yeah because this is about gratitude and
when we focus on gratitude we feel
better and what i will say is if you are
worried about tension over the holidays
you have a home you have food you have
company
tune into that if we focus on that we
get our perspective back and it makes it
easier to bear the hard parts i'm just
going to think of your voice because it
brings me zen
yeah come on get stressed out
thank you so much you're welcome yeah
lisa you gave us some great options love
it thank you